okay Maggie look in the breakdown gee
Haskell
they don't come through that door make
good cop bad cop don't fall for that all
right she sees the one you want in
Hollywood everything important in an
interrogation is seen or heard the cops
grimace the loud yelling treating a
suspect hostile the light that's way too
bright but in a real interrogation its
flipped around everything important is
unseen unheard on the surface real
interrogations look boring the cop is
nice to you that give you a drink they
dress in plain clothes
it's almost disarming especially if this
is more of what you were expecting but
that's the point
under the boring disarming surface of an
interrogation you find a whole host of
psychological traps and mental tricks
that are designed to make you confess it
starts from the moment you walk in every
inch of an interrogation room has been
designed to make you feel isolated and
powerless the room is small cramped the
walls are blank and there are no windows
you'll be placed in an uncomfortable
straight back often metal chair while
the cops chair will be able to roll this
becomes important later on the next move
is a hurdle that cops have to get over
when you go to jail a cop is legally
required to tell you you have the right
to shut up this actually turns out to be
the only great advice you're gonna get
talking to cops is always a bad move and
for the cop what this means is that
their first priority is making you
ignore this advice and go against
everything you've ever heard they have
to convince you to play the game with
them the first questions are
deliberately not about the investigation
they want to appear trustworthy so that
you'll talk to them about the case mama
step 8
downtown I'm a big coffee I don't know
if you're a coffee guy ramabai's reneus
so no I say that all right good
there's a plane going up there we're
gonna cereal if you get hungry anything
else just let me know okay how come you
get more than one middle name you know I
got three middle name well that's what
my parents thought I may be an only
child so Amy after everybody so I got
named after your grandfather two uncles
so I know what you I know what you're
going through there cuz my initials I
get teased above the other goal behind
these innocent questions is to establish
a behavioral baseline they want to see
how you act when you're telling the
truth finally when they're ready they'll
ask you something like this well let's
let's do this before any questions okay
the right to remain silent
what this says here do you understand
once you're talking they'll first get a
statement about what happened after
hearing it if the cop thinks you might
have done it if the facts aren't lining
up or if you're acting shady they may
move to the accusation phase in the
accusation phase they will confidently
accuse you of the crime the cop will say
in no uncertain terms you did it we know
you did it and we've got evidence for it
your vehicle drove up the side of
Jessica Lloyd's house your boots walked
to the back of Jessica Lloyd's house on
the evening of the 28th and 29th of
January you and I both know you're at
Jessica Lloyd's house and I need to know
why but here's the catch they'll claim
they have evidence for your guilt even
when they don't this nosy neighbor or
whatever were in a colin has monitored
and I'm not going to tell you how okay
just think about it with today's
technology monitored what was going on
in front of this residence that they
were calling to complain about until
police arrived I can prove it I can go
in front of the judge and say hey look
bro we want to fuckin you want us to
play this video you want us to show you
the fingerprint results he wants to show
you the GRE on this the goal here is to
make you think that you're already
caught they already have you why bother
resisting and lying about it when they
already know you did it just confess so
it's it's one of the easiest
investigations I've had it's fuckin
there and you can't lie about that bro
you can't tell us that you didn't fuckin
fire that fourth shot anymore
you can't during this phase of the
interrogation the interrogator doesn't
want you to deny the crime even though
you'll want to vocalize denials
reinforces your position so cops make an
interesting move they try to not let you
vocalize denials in the first place if
possible they'll often interrupt you or
not stop talking to allow Briggs to let
you speak up instead they'll keep the
pressure on by reinforcing the idea that
they a hundred percent already have you
caught you know it they know it let's
just drop the charade the next phase is
theme development after accusing someone
the cops will try to provide themes to
offer moral or psychological
justifications for the crime nobody's
going to confess if they think it makes
them look bad or their dignities at
stake so the cops want to give you a way
to lose without losing face this will
never be used in your favor when the
confession goes to trial of course these
are simply mind games that are used to
get the confession we sort of believe
that it could have been a fucking
accident it could have been accidental
discharge okay but when you don't when
you're completely denying that then then
I got to think another way bro
I don't believe you're a cold-blooded
killer no I don't believe that at all
nothing suggests that to me I think
you're a smart guy and I think you
involved in a situation that you
probably shouldn't have there's a
difference between you going in and
saying I'm gonna kill somebody and
you're going in I'm trying to help
somebody and then shit goes bad there's
that's way different things that we're
talking about what other option is there
I don't think you want the cold blooded
psychopath function I might be wrong
because I don't get me wrong I've met
guys who actually kind of enjoyed the
notoriety got off on it I don't see that
I saw that you wouldn't be back in your
talk again quite frankly but maybe I'm
wrong
maybe you got me fooled I don't know
this is where most people start to break
most people often go into a passive mood
when they're about to confess looking
beat down and acting quiet this is the
first time that you'll seriously start
considering confession there's even a
physical tell called the surrender
position that cops look for to know when
you're about to confess it looks like
this when the cop seizes he will
continue to reiterate all the themes
that have been developed so far we know
you did it
we have evidence and good guys come
clean in addition to deploying
psychological measures the cop will also
deploy physical ones remember that the
cops chair can roll and during this time
he will often move closer in order to
ramp up the tension in the room you will
feel trapped like there's nowhere to go
and meanwhile a physically intimidated
cop is telling you that you have to
confess you must confess finally there's
a moment when the tension that has been
building up for hours finally breaks you
can almost see it
minimize the impact on my wife so do I
how do we do that well we start by
telling the truth
it's okay
so where is she in a minute and once the
cop gets their confession it's all over
your chance of being let off go to
almost zero your plea deals get a lot
worse and you have gained absolutely
nothing from the exchange except for the
knowledge of just how good cops are at
beating you in the interrogation room
and I just think I'd look guilty if I
hired a lawyer yeah actually it's
getting arrested
that makes people look guilty even the
innocent ones and innocent people get
arrested every day and they find
themselves in a little room with a
detective
who acts like he's their best friend
talked to me he says help me clear this
thing up but you don't need a lawyer
only guilty people need lawyers and boom
hey that's when it all goes south it's
time to come clean are you following me
on these platforms we have communities
on reddit and discord and the bigger
they grow the more fun they are also I
share a more personal side of my life on
twitter and instagram so follow if
you're into that kind of stuff finally
thank you to my patrons guys if you're
not a patron please it helps my life so
much to be making a little bit of money
from this channel I don't need to make a
lot but every little bit counts so much
so thank you guys to everyone who is
supporting me music producers are as
always linked here and below and I will
see you guys next time conviction of
your conviction man it's simple addition
evidences with us gonna put you in
prison so give us the sentence talking
about your contrition it's just a simple
admission that may help your condition
and that's the story of how they get you
here's one final admonition don't talk
without a lawyer
[Music]